how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we're going
to be talking about deadpool
3 in the mcu lately it's been relatively
quiet about deadpool 3. we know that
ryan reynolds is supposedly striking up
a
huge deal the biggest deal in marvel
studios history
with marvel studios to sign on to do
multiple different films
of course reprising his role as deadpool
and we know that ryan reynolds has
indeed
met with marvel studios and we even do
have clips of him saying that deadpool 3
is in development at marvel studios
right now
yet another deadpool in the franchise uh
yeah yeah we're
working on it right now with the whole
team we're over at marvel now which is
like
the big leagues all of a sudden it's
kind of crazy so yeah we're working but
the big questions that people have been
wondering are how exactly is deadpool
going to go from the fox universe to the
mcu
and what exactly is deadpool 3 going to
be about is it going to be
retconned or will deadpool just simply
break the fourth wall and acknowledge
that he has indeed
swapped universes well according to a
leak that was found online it's actually
going to be pretty good and deadpool
might actually show us what he was up to
during
the events of avengers in-game and as it
turns out the snap might actually be
how deadpool ends up in our main marvel
cinematic universe so i'll break down
everything you need to know about this
leak but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a tony stark funko pop i'm
picking a winner on
friday so this leak was posted on 4chan
and i'll read through the whole entire
thing and then we'll go back and break
it down piece by piece
it starts off by saying a new mcu
deadpool is indeed
in the works reynolds and feige have
finally come to an agreement on what the
movie will be
it's a half sequel to the established
deadpool series and
half reboot which is essentially the way
that i expected them to go
but it goes on and continues to say that
rhett reese and paul
wernick will be returning to write the
script along with ryan reynolds who
already has a bare bones draft
constructed that he used to pitch the
movie to kevin feige of marvel studios
it will be titled something along the
lines of deadpool
retconn and will be set during the snap
the film will open the entire
established supporting cast of the
deadpool franchise getting snapped away
with weasel getting snapped off screen
to avoid using tj miller which will be
referenced in a fourth
wall break now tj miller apparently
right now has some sexual harassment
allegations against him whether or not
those are true or
false this is something that disney
would not take likely so the fact that
he would get snapped off screen to where
they would not have to put him in the
movie makes a lot of sense
but continuing it says that deadpool
will assume this happened due to him
time traveling at the end of deadpool 2
and he will attempt to fix it
the running joke is that deadpool has
always been in the mcu and there's
definitely nothing strange about that
t-rey is the villain the film will be
rated r and released under the 20th
century banner it will work a lot like
the sony spider-man films where the mcu
is canon to deadpool
but not necessarily vice versa which is
actually something that a lot of us have
expected for a pretty long time
it says that reynolds signed a
historically lucrative five film
contract with marvel studios
this will be a big headline when the
news breaks the money is insane
and it says to expect this news by
december 10th and it will most likely be
announced
by ryan reynolds on his twitter
instagram and possibly in character as
deadpool now right off the bat there's
no way of knowing whether this
is true or not like with all leaks it
could be fake but it also could be real
because we had a lot of real ones come
out during the time of avengers infinity
war and avengers in game and
not to mention we did have some for
spider-man far from home as well so you
never know
but this would actually be a fairly
perfect way to introduce deadpool into
the mcu
and let's break it down on why that is
now of course at the end of deadpool 2
during the post-credits scene deadpool
got his hands on cable's time travel
device
and negasonic teenage warhead and yukio
managed to fix it for him
then deadpool started to go back in time
and he started fixing or altering
other timelines now most of us know that
this is going to play a big role of
marvel's phase 4 and kang the conqueror
is most likely coming because he's upset
about all of the different timelines
that have been changed but this is going
to make deadpool think that him messing
around with time travel is actually what
caused the snap
so the film is going to start with
everybody that deadpool knows
getting snapped so he's going to think
it's his fault and he's going to go
around and try and fix it
now there is one part about this plot
leak that says that the running joke of
the film is going to be that deadpool
has always been in the mcu
and i actually think that this is quite
a clever way
to put him in our universe because
clearly he existed in the fox universe
before there's no arguing with that
in fact in deadpool 2 when he's at
professor x's mansion we even do see
some of the x-men so the joke will be
throughout the movie
deadpool you've always existed in the
mcu why is that so hard for you to
understand and he'll most likely make a
joke about it the whole entire film
claiming that he's from the fox universe
and probably cracking jokes at the fox
universe's
expense along with the other x-men as
well now what might happen with deadpool
3 is that
it might actually span over five years
as well in avengers in-game we had the
avengers fight thanos in separate groups
but then they lost and we went through a
five year gap
that's when they came back together and
they defeated thanos this all happened
over a five year span
and since this leak does say that the
mcu is going to be cannon to deadpool
that means that he's not going to be
able to fix the snap on his own
and he's going to have to wait until the
hulk and iron man
snap but here's the really really
awesome idea about having deadpool
retconned into the mcu to where he was
in the mcu the whole entire time
combined with the idea that deadpool is
actually trying to fix
the snap because he believes that it's
his fault this opens it up to have
deadpool
secretly be in the background of all the
events of avengers infinity war and
avengers in-game
the entire time that means we could
actually see the return of some of our
favorite marvel heroes
for example they could show deadpool and
wakanda fighting alongside the avengers
the entire time
obviously they would make a joke how
nobody noticed him or how just nobody
gave it any thought because they assumed
he's just another
masked hero and he's fighting on their
side so who cares they could even show
him in the final battle of avengers in
game where all of the heroes come
together right before captain america
says avengers assemble
in fact i really wouldn't be surprised
if somehow deadpool
managed to wield mjolnir in a really
hilarious way but if this
is true that is the potential for this
movie deadpool actually being
involved with all of these scenes in the
mcu deadpool inserting himself
in a very hilarious way now as far as
the villain t-rey goes it's quite an
interesting choice however
t-ray was a very important character in
the deadpool series in the comics he's
deadpool's archenemy for many different
issues and almost everything that
happened to deadpool was a part of an
elaborate plan orchestrated by t-ray
t-rey is a mercenary for hire that would
later go on to develop sorcerer-like
powers primarily voodoo and he also has
the superpower of being able to break
the fourth wall as well
so t-ray being the villain of the
deadpool 3 film might actually make for
some pretty good comedy now as far as
deadpool being rated r but still going
under the 20th century banner
that's been rumored before and it seems
like it could work again as it was
mentioned it could work just like how
the marvel sony deal works it's released
under sony but it's in associations with
marvel studios
this way disney doesn't really have to
do a rated r film since it seems like
they're trying to avoid that
however the former ceo of disney said
that they weren't really opposed to
doing rated r films so we'll have to see
what happens there but as far as a
deadpool
3 film is concerned this would actually
be a pretty good movie in my personal
opinion
i would love to see deadpool retconned
into the events of avengers infinity war
and avengers end game i would actually
love to see him interact with thanos
because i think it would be hilarious
and not to mention that in the comics
deadpool and thanos share a love
lady death so there is a connection
there between deadpool
and thanos but we'll have to wait until
we have more information about this film
to find out so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu and
deadpool 3 news big thank you to heroes
hideout.com for providing the tony stark
funko pop and you can check out their
website if you love funko's be sure to
let me know
what you think about this deadpool 3
plot lake in the comments down below and
let me know what you think about
deadpool being retconned into the events
of infinity war
and endgame for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof